i referenced the intercept when talking
about
uh donald trump and they called him the
most honest and deceitful president
have you guys seen the intercept story
that came out about the dc riot squad
we talked about it yeah okay yep for
those that are listening at home
we are good friends with the riot squad
they are awesome
people they come on the show every so
often whenever there's like a big event
richie and you know jorge and and the
whole crew
they're here and we talk about what
happened like hey you were on the ground
tell me your tell me your thoughts
and they're always very explicitly like
we're not political we're not pro
or anti like you know we can criticize
violence and all that stuff
richie is very very like strict about
like it's not my political opinion i'll
tell you what they did
you know like antifa did these things
that happened i was there he told us
about what happened in dc in january 6.
he was down there at the capitol filming
it and he got smeared by the new york
times they called him a writer because
he was there filming and his shirt got
it came off
anyway the intercept writes this uh uh
this they make this 24-minute video
claiming that the riot squad our friends
are like right-wing misinformation to
distort the facts and smear black lives
matter
so we have this from the national review
they say we shouldn't need the riot
squad but we do a response to the
intercept
they say if you were lucky enough to get
off the internet for any extended period
of time
last summer you probably would have had
no idea that cities across the country
were being consumed by political
violence on a scale unseen since the
1960s
if in may and june you limited your
media diet to the major newspapers
cnn and msnbc you would have been
unaware that intense property damage and
physical violence
was being perpetrated by rioters each
and every night in kenosha
portland and just about every other
major city and i want to point out in
kenosha there's a video
where an old man had a store was being
burned and looted and when he ran up
trying to stop people someone bashed him
over the back of the head with a rock
letting him on the ground bleeding out
they say extremist agitators
many of whom traveled from city to city
looking for trouble assaulted bystanders
destroyed businesses and torched
buildings the only reason we know
who was responsible and how they managed
to run wild in formerly sleepy downtowns
is because of journalists like daily
callers richie mcginnis shelby talcott
jorge ventura and town hall's julio
rosas and we've had all of them in
in the studio and i will stress they are
good friends of the show after new york
times reporters and cable news talking
heads left the scenes of daytime
protests
mcginnis talcott ventura roses stayed on
the street to document the destruction
that reliably followed mcginnis got so
close to the action of kenosha
he rendered first aid to the man whom
kyle written house fatally shot
yet the intercept did they tried
smearing
richie by making it seem like he was
withholding evidence
because certainly he should have had
video footage of what happened right why
didn't he release it
he was rendering first aid to a guy who
got shot he was like being a human being
and not just a human being but you
whether the person's bad or good
somebody willing to render first aid in
a critical situation like that that's
that's a
courageous person you ever see you ever
see the patriot with
mel gibson yeah and and and mel gibson's
in his house and he's got
uh redcoats and continental you know uh
army
and they're all being rendered we do
this we do this because we're good
people
yep uh and then the bad guy he was the
british guy he's like kill them all or
whatever and it like made britain look
like extremists or whatever they got
really mad about it
but you know the point is the bad guys
are the ones
who who let you die you know like when
the joker is falling to his death batman
always saves him
yeah batman's the good guy who doesn't
want you to die he just is trying to do
right even though sometimes it's hard
decisions
they're going to say a year later the
intercept's robert mackey seems upset
the reporting done by the daily caller
and town hall is inconvenient to his
political agenda
in a transparent attempt at the sort of
guilt by association that activists
posing as reporters just love
mackie lumps talcott and mcginnis in
with fabulous
who posted deceptively edited clips of
writing on social media to start outrage
labeling the lot of them the riot squad
i'm sorry i just got to point out they
call themselves the right what's the
right squad that actually is a cool name
yeah that's like a that's a cool
nickname we had three of the crew
here on the show and i was like what
should we put and i think it was richie
right yeah he's like the dc right okay
because they're journalists who are down
there covering these things and it's
it's really it's
it's the reason i bring this up is for
one i am personally offended at the
insult to
good friends of this show like we had
richie here hanging out rollerblading
he's like in one of the vlogs like he's
literally just a friend who's hanging
out
he's a good dude he's not super
political he's like a surfer guy a
skateboarder
and simply by doing journalism they try
to destroy him that's the name of the
game
i will also mention i'm offended that we
get we get no smears in this thing they
don't mention
we want our i think no no i'm being
somewhat facetious but our third biggest
clip from the show
was richie mcginnis telling the story of
what happened in kenosha
explaining here's what happened here's
where i was and that's and that's it
that's because there was too much
context in the clip that's why you guys
didn't give any love they were well
right because if they showed any of that
people would have been like oh he's
straight up saying he's not political he
started saying i have no opinion on
kyle and what's happening it'll be
fleshed out in court and then he sat
here and we interviewed him and he said
here's what
i saw here's what happened that's it and
that was a major uh uh
that's one of our biggest clips and so i
look to what they're doing i used to do
the same thing i used to go down the
ground and i
would report all this stuff it got
dangerous of course now the intercept
glenn greenwald quit it's become a
vicious political monster
full of lies and manipulation and now
real journalists have emerged that are
threatening the narrative
defending the extremists so going back
to what you're talking about with
marxist taking over that's why i wanted
to talk about this
they can't have real journalists yeah
the irony is isn't that why the
intercept was made
isn't that why glenn greenwald did this
and found funding and did this was so
that we could have real reporting so
that people would do
things without fear and they would go
after the real power structures that try
to keep people from knowing what's going
on
that's what it was for and this is the
group now who's divorced themselves so
far
from what their actual mission was that
they're now attacking people who are
doing i'm sorry you want to talk about
an organization that divorced themselves
from the mission
there's a group it's called free press
i've known many of the people that free
press for a long time
the name of their organizat organization
free press
they would fight censorship and defend
the first amendment and the right to
report and all that good stuff and they
have a website freepress.net
if they agree with you i remember when
they used to be i
i've uh i i don't i don't it's been a
long time but i've interviewed people
there
i've had several meetings with many of
the people who worked this organization
and then one day i saw one of their top
people who i had known for some time
demanding censorship that alex jones be
banned
and i said that's strange why are you
advocating for censorship i thought you
were free press
something happened to this organization
where it became woke
and their mission was no longer about
supporting free speech it was about
shutting down hate speech how did that
happen
i don't know but you look at the
intercept and you look at how glenn
greenwald
he's like hey we're doing the snowden
documents we're gonna make fearless
reporting we're gonna start this
organization and it got so bad
the dude quit glenn greenwald who
founded the intercept
quit his own company and now he's doing
independent work
and they call him you know alt-right and
far-right or whatever which is hilarious
because he's he's on the left
politically i mean very clearly
and he disagrees a lot on policy with
things that i would believe in
but he's what i would like my opposition
to be
we can actually have a conversation on
policy we can actually find some kind of
solution within our differences say hey
we actually agree on this one part of it
let's at least implement that you can't
do that when the other group of people
behave the way that we see the current
party behaving or i mean you
whatever the intercept is i mean this
video was
look in the video the guy says this guy
robert mackey he's like
the videos they produce are distortions
and activists have taken up cameras to
combat these distortions
then he says much of the footage we got
from january 6 at the capitol was from
these
riot squad people because the right
trusted them and i'm like whoa
hold on either they're reporting both
sides
or it's a distortion but it can't be
both
and if it is a distortion what this guy
is reporting now the intercept
has said that the footage depicted
from these journalists on january 6 is
unreliable distortions
not telling us the truth okay let's get
rid of it as evidence the fbi should be
allowed to use it in fact
if i if if one of these guys like if i
was one of these people on trial
whatever i'd have my lawyer be like
your honor take a look at this reporting
from the intercept clearly these videos
are fabrication
and distortions as the intercept has
reported you can't trust these videos
sorry yep release the old ladies you've
gotten solitary
yeah seriously it shows you that
these people have no principles they
never did
but more importantly it shows the divide
between the moral frameworks of
the the disparate factions and the
culture war why you and i probably have
different politics on
several issues glenn greenwald clearly
but glenn would easily have a
conversation about all these things
we can disagree on policy but when our
moral frameworks are very similar
then we're able to have the conversation
because the goal is actually to improve
the system
when you're when your ideology is built
on just having power and oppressing
those who oppose you
then you will lie cheat and steal to
take whatever you want it also kind of
highlights a problem in corporate law
this is a little bit of a side note but
that you can
you can sell a company to a new owner
with a new ethos and they can
they can have the same name company name
but it's a different company i mean it
might have the same ip but
when someone the company is the people
that run the company for the most part i
mean that's what coming is
so that disturbs me maybe we should
change it so that you have to change the
name of a company if it gets sold
because disney's not disney walt
disney's dead
i'll be honest i've never thought about
that that's it's an interesting thing to
think about you know i think
i i'd have to think about that one in
terms of like i knew i knew a guy who
had a cyber security company
and what he told me was there was a
hostile takeover
the company was stripped and sold off
for for parts basically
but it was still a publicly traded
company so then someone else who wanted
to
start a new company just bought it and
then started doing probiotics
so it's like if you were an investor in
this company
and you were interested in cyber
security one day you woke up and they
were selling probiotics and you're like
what
is not the same company different
product different people different money
different part of the country but it is
the same company on paper
that's bizarre i've never thought about
that but you're totally right that
disney's not the same company at all as
what walt disney envisioned
not even really close and the intercept
yeah
obviously 180 from what 100 percent was
looking down
i i have been noticing that glenn
greenwald now has this really unique
position where he can critique the
intercept perfectly because he knows
them
inside and out so he's been tweeting at
them he's like you guys are
doing this wrong you know this is
unethical and you've now put you know
this target on the backs of these really
serious really invested reporters who've
been they've worked hard
they have they have put themselves in so
much danger and i'm saying this is
somebody like i don't know them
i've watched their work i've seen what
they've done i have not seen one thing
from any of them
that shows that they have a personal
political persuasion to what's going on
okay i actually try very hard to make
sure it's not a part of the which is
like
if anything you know if i saw some
people on the left doing that i would
i'd have respect for what they're doing
you know somebody like
glenn he's at least open when he is
being political right
about why and what the reasoning is
can't have the truth man
but you know you how do you manipulate
people and so it's just the the
duplicitousness of this report from this
robert mackie guy where he's like
they're distortions
and they're also the source of all the
evidence from january 6. yep
yeah okay full of it i i think the only
clear
determination is if people like richie
are going to cover the left and the
right
and it'll be used as evidence against
people on the right he's clearly just a
journalist
he's just telling people what's going on
the problem is
they like it when he makes the right
look bad they have to forgive that
they don't like it when he makes black
lives matter look bad they have to
condemn that
the real problem is that real journalism
is a threat to their ability to attain
power consolidate power and keep it
because if you have real journalism
going on you have real reporting that's
unbiased that is one of the most
dangerous things to them and that's why
it's been all but eliminated if regular
people knew what they were doing
it would be over and that's the problem
so they need to do everything in their
power to obfuscate the truth
so that regular people don't know what's
going on i mean you look at kyle
rittenhouse right
so i i'm on reddit and i see a story and
it's like kyle right now blah blah
and the top comment is the dude
literally cross state lines the gun to
hunt down protesters it's not hard or
something like that and i'm like none of
that is true
no none of it's true he worked in
kenosha it was someone else's gun he was
asked to defend a building
he rendered aid to the some of the
writers it's a complicated story yep
but in order to push your agenda you
need
kyra has to be the villain you need the
lies yep
and who fired first it wasn't kyle yeah
it was exactly i don't remember the
guy's name but he fired it looks like
into the air he might it might
might not have been into the air so a
lot of people thought it was because
it's a grainy footage where you see a
flash and i think it's going up
but i read one report that said he
actually fired directions it doesn't
really matter honestly he brandished he
fired and if you have a weapon
and you perceive that person as a threat
and then you have a mob of people
there who want to hurt you you have a
duty and a right to defend yourself
you know that's not hard to figure out i
think cat will get life
you do absolutely look you look at
what's going on now with chauvin and the
other other cops did you did you hear
the latest yeah i
feel differently about that than i do
the written house case i think that on
the written cow's case there's going to
be somebody on that jury hopefully
multiple people who go
and look at this by the letter of the
law and say
this kid was defending himself maybe
because in the other case i think
they're
gonna if it's they're gonna give him the
worst in the floyd case if it's if it's
the the trial is in the kenosha
kenosha's 50-50
between democrat republican so then
you'll at least have some on the jury
being like no i'm not convincing this
kid so
hung jury at the very least however i
think most people will probably just be
cowards
and when they're in the deliberations
they're gonna someone's gonna go okay so
who doesn't want their house burned down
all right guilty all right let's get out
of here that is the biggest fear which
tells you everything about where we are
in terms of
what time it is during this color
revolution we're at the point where
mobs run justice so we have mob run
justice
what's the next step what does the
future look like for people if you don't
stand up now
and that's my argument to people is like
now is the time to do it because if
you're going to wait till people knock
on your door
that's going to be too late this is my
issue currently with police departments
we see it mostly in major cities but i
wouldn't be surprised if it comes even
in tennessee
what do you think is going to happen
when
in kenosha which is fairly republican in
many it's it's like 50 50.
they're burning down buildings the
police didn't stop them it was for days
they were doing this
so then regular people are going to say
i don't want my building burned down
just make it stop throw the kid in jail
whatever fun i don't care
you look at these stories where like in
milwaukee the black lives matter people
were outside this guy's home
he brandished a shotgun through the
window the cops went into his house and
arrested him while they cheered for this
it's insane
and and that group of people previously
someone in that group had set fire to
another house they were protesting at
so this guy probably was actually scared
and brandished a shotgun
maybe he shouldn't have pointed it
directly at them but he gets arrested he
was at his house though he was in his
own house
brandish all away you know somebody's
threatening your house brandish away
in tennessee we have very clear laws
about that type of thing you don't even
have to be inside the house
um to have things start to pop off so
so we're seeing this more and more where
the cops are gonna sit down and there's
gonna be three or four cops and they're
gonna see a riot and they're gonna go
what's the riot mad about well some guy
said you know
a racial slur well what do we do well
he's allowed to do it's the first
amendment but they won't stop
rioting if we arrest the guy will they
stop they might
just arrest the guy and the cops are
going to be like sir you're under arrest
that's what happened in milwaukee the
guy was in his own home
and they were outside of his house
people who had previously burned down
another house or set fire to another
house
they didn't burn it down but they set
fire to it twice and so he's probably
scared
and he's the one who gets arrested look
at the mccloskeys they enter private
property
they're walking on private property and
they come out with guns
and they're in trouble now maybe people
are going to be like in missouri you
can't do that fine whatever
in west virginia you definitely can if
people walk on your property you can
walk up to them with your gun points and
get off my property same with tennessee
100 so it's different in different
states
i think it should be that if you enter
my property i can pull up my weapon and
say
turn around right now or i will defend
my property in new jersey for instance
where we were before this the reason we
left is that
they call it a partial castle doctrine
which basically means
it's not if someone breaks into your
home you are legally obligated to
retreat from your own home
where it doesn't matter that's called
fleeing it's not retreat you retreat
back
so you're in your underwear you're in
bed your door's kicked open
and you go what do i do well you can't
use lethal force
go into the deposit you have to leave
your house you have to leave your house
only if you can prove you had no
opportunity to leave your home safely
are you allowed to then use lethal force
to defend yourself which means you'll be
arrested charged and then you can
charged and then you could argue to the
judge why you were why you were in your
right to defend yourself in your own
scene
in tennessee your car also counts as
part of your castle wow
nice so um somebody tries to get in your
car car jackie you can shoot him in the
face and you're good
um if that's allowed in tennessee in
west virginia you're allowed to shoot to
stop someone from
from from entering your property which
is like what i always tell people like
don't
trespass out here okay in new york
people trespass and they laugh about
them like don't do that
in west virginia i don't think anyone's
going to shoot you because people
aren't insane but they'll be legally
allowed to do it if you go onto their
property
so don't do it yeah they'll probably
just walk out with a shotgun and be like
you got 10 seconds
yeah off my property thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time